regardez on veut des meilleurs invités
de la saison rien on invite est préféré
par hbo vous le savez qu'elle est sans
clavier est avec moi pony
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inégaux tu n'étais pas forcément ouais
c'est à rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si je peux résumer en un mot rigueur
monde
[Applaudissements]
alors la balayette incombe au tacle de
sa coupe de cheveux en brisant pc
surtout colis toujours tu n'as donc tu
n'avais rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'émission à succès de la chaîne il me
semble nrj12 entre comme ça qui
s'appelait oif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que ça se passe bien c'est nul
entre nous merci à tous en tout cas des
volumes cette année
marlène sais pas qui une de mes invités
préféré c'est à dire ouais je vous le
dis